it's been a week of peril uncertainty
life and death decisions
but at last a british family of 13 has
made it through this cauldron
[Music]
safe at last on the other side of the
barrier at kabul airport waiting for an
raf flight home
everywhere around this city everywhere
around the world on the back here i'm
big gun when i get here i'm just so
relaxed now i'm thinking i'm like back
to the uk i'm so happy now
the sahih family had flown to kabul from
heathrow in late july for a double
wedding in the afghan capital in early
august they traveled with young children
and were booked on a flight last monday
that never left
by tuesday their world was caving in
the taliban were conducting searches
below their flat
and speaking by video phones
told me how the taliban had taken their
car
i said my it's my own car it's not the
government's car i said they said we
don't bother we don't care who you are
and just they put the gun on my head
and they took the car
they're a tall one just they came back
to my house
it got worse
sabrina kept a video diary
this was just after the taliban had been
into their apartment and threatened his
uncle
johannes you're so scared i don't know
what we should do
and they said
this is why you keep these guys in your
home this came from
united kingdom you should kick them out
and just
till yesterday he was hiding in this
house
ajmal hibibi was the man hiding them
between his flat and safety was a rat
run of bandits and checkpoints this is
footage from another family trying to
get through the city but on thursday the
sahiris were on these streets attempting
to get to the airport when they were
stopped by the taliban we tried to go
for the flight and the taliban attackers
and they they had me with their gun with
the ak-47 in the middle of my chairs and
i fell down on the floor
so they had my uncle as well they had me
and they had
these guys as well
they knew even if they got past the
taliban the crush outside the airport
was another hazard but they understand
why people want to get out
people want to run away from this
country they hate this country now
because this country is gone now in my
opinion this country is finished never
gonna be back on
back like same before
exhausted aching to get home just hours
after they got out people were fatally
crushed at the gates they'd passed for
once luck was on their side outside of
here others still wait for it to visit
them
jason farrell sky news